putin has gravely miscalculated in his
aboriginal assault on a sovereign nation
he has underestimated the extraordinary
fortitude of the ukrainian people and
the unity and resolve of the free world
in standing up to his barbarism
the un general assembly will vote later
today and we call on every nation to
join us in condemning russia and
demanding that putin turn his tanks
around today the disasters and emergency
committee is launching its ukraine
appeal
and every pound donated by the british
people will be matched by the government
starting with 20 million pounds will the
prime minister meet with me to discuss
this and will they amend the uk war
crimes act and will we support the icc
prosecution for putin for his crimes of
aggression against the people
uh well mr speaker i'm in principle of
course happy to uh meet the the
gentleman
at any stage but i can tell him that
what we have seen already from vladimir
putin's regime in the use of the
munitions that they have already been uh
they've been dropping on as on innocent
civilians uh mr speaker uh in my view
already fully qualifies as as a war
crime and i know that the uh that the
icc prosecutor is already investigating
and i'm sure the whole house uh will
support that i want to welcome to our
gallery the ukraine ambassador
you're right
[Applause]
you're excellent
we generally do not allow applause in
this chamber
but on this occasion the host quite
rightly
wants to demonstrate over respect and
support for your country and its people
in the most difficult of times